is that are those the same uh um
microphones you bought when we first
started doing the podcast yeah they
they're the ones that i use for all my
[ __ ]
the whole thing that started it all
the thing that also got i mean i don't
know you can figure
victor
check check
like check the thing that started at all
the uh the thing that got uh yo
[Applause]
the thing that started it all
we are on
podcast 69.
pilpa 69 69 is interesting because it's
like if you in put the number upside
down
then you have a six and a nine so that's
why it's an interesting number that we
got
pill pod 69
promise the last time that we ever bring
up daddy
is it really the last time i can't yeah
i don't know if we should make a promise
promises are made to be broken we're
making an effort okay so we're live if
you're watching this on youtube then
we're live this
litvic in the flesh
yo yo
the other vic politics victor politics
politics guy the og the og
matt mcmanus stop you know him and
myself
pills believe it or not we used to do
this we started off doing it in person
and then obviously the pandemic hit but
this is probably the first time we've
done it in person since before the
pandemic right this is actually the
first time i've ever done a full one of
these right because we did one together
that one time oh yeah which we didn't
even get to release because of the
shitty audio that was such a good
interview too
yeah so this is my first time doing a
live one ever it's awesome that's cool
anyway you're gonna miss daddy after
today because
i'm vowing never to speak of him again
he left u of t so i don't know he's not
an academic anymore now he's just uh
i heard i heard one of my professors i
think tweeting about how he's so happy
that that no longer does he have to say
because i go to university of toronto
that my colleague or someone can refer
oh he's your colleague
yeah i'd also like to say pills that
they promised that like a nightmare on
elm street would end with seven movies
and we've had many many a freddie and
kruger adventure since then so let's not
jump the gun
but it is fitting that we're talking
about lobster daddy in our first
in-person pod it should be mentioned too
that it should be mentioned that eric
isn't here maybe you mentioned it and i
didn't notice oh yeah eric's got the
cove so actually is it confirmed no
they're not allowed to get test them but
it's sore throat and and nasal stuff so
oh yeah it's the eric i'm sorry not here
we love you alma covid um you can you
can see that it's friday night so we got
some drinks
we kind of stopped drinking on the pot i
think it's when we stopped recording on
friday nights
well whenever we when we first started
doing it before matt's time we would
always drink because it would be an
in-person thing and we always did it uh
like
as a hangout excuse me but then coveted
and i don't know at least for me i
remember you guys were drinking still i
like eric was drinking on the pod even
when it was over zoom pills i feel like
you were drinking you probably drink i
have this weird thing where i don't
really like drinking when i'm not
physically in with other people i don't
know why that is i've tried i've like
tried to
even be like oh i'm home from a day from
like a busy day at work like let me uh
have a drink and i just don't like the
way it makes me feel it's like my brain
turns off in a way that i want to be
around other people this is why
i don't advice yeah and i don't like it
you should just stand up straight with
your shoulders back and suck back some
wine victor it's your dirty room yelling
at you that's really what's going on
there you gotta just set your house in
order and you'll be fine actually
victor's house is extremely clean
for a bachelor dude you know do you want
to know i'm i'm not technically a
bachelor but yes i live alone um
i think i had to throw that in there
like no i'm not a bachelor [ __ ] well i
mean i'm but i'm just saying i i'm not a
cook you know what's funny though my you
know speaking of like clean rooms i
would say that the only thing in my like
the only thing that i don't actually do
regularly that is like a normal
stereotypical clean thing is i don't
actually make my bed
really i don't i don't care it's like
the one thing i get up and it's like
there's no point and it drives my
girlfriend [ __ ] crazy because she's
like it's like the first thing she does
every time so i always like make my bed
but it's the only thing my room is clean
like i i'm i'm
everything is clean it's just i just
leave the bed
i just leave the i just leave the
blanket like shuffled around i just
don't care about like well i'm gonna get
back in it anyway anyway i don't know
yeah you kind of break with the grad
school cliche because i've been to your
place a couple times and it is always
immaculate like very very nice like
if i wasn't married then
my state of being would decay pretty
rapidly unlike some people i know it
never reaches like a complete minimal
threshold but it definitely can reach a
pretty low threshold so i definitely
believe you
yeah well you see pills are you when you
when you were a bachelor were you clean
look at this place this place is
beautiful there's there's even plans
you're not this is not you that's that
this is the i don't know if this is you
all right let's get to it
from when he was living
let's get to the content
thank you matt
all right so you might see a few cuts
here we're going to try to run through
it we have a bunch of clips i can
already tell which one was going to be
the first cut of the infamous
of the informative address joe rogan
interview with daddy where daddy
i don't know i think completely
discredited himself as an intellectual i
mean that's my opinion
and then the the
the kids in the chat are gonna say uh
you haven't read all of his books
but matt actually has read all of his so
did you watch that so did you watch did
you watch the david pakman thing i sent
you then no okay cause that's exactly
what david pakman says in his clip he
literally says like
he's like you know i'm going to be
careful with what i said i think he
described the interview as he was like
he was like bizarre interview that seems
like a skit is like the name of the of
the description and he says like he's
like no matter what i'm going to say
people in the chat are going to say well
you're just saying that because you
haven't actually read his books and you
don't understand can i just say a genius
of what he's saying having read all his
books yeah you actually have a right to
i actually kind of enjoyed maps of
meaning and i pointed this out in our
text like i think it has insights here
and there and it's an enjoyable reading
and stuff it does actually make me kind
of depressed because he has started to
approach self parody like to a threshold
that we really really tried to avoid
when we were writing about him we're
like we're going to take him straight as
a serious intellectual now it's just
really hard to do that because what the
[ __ ] do you even say when somebody's
like climate is everything or the bible
is like truer than truth oh my god are
we going to watch that clip that part's
that oh my god that part's my favorite
okay we got we got some fracking coming
up we got some
biblical interpretation yeah coming up
that part is that just to give some
context too for how far you know daddy
has fallen i mean like back in the early
2010s he was actually like a fairly
respected junior and you know about u of
yeah at u of t around then i did not
with us i was t
actually take a class with him but some
of my friends were associated with the
jungian society that he was running so
he was like a pretty respected like
moderately cool professor who like
talked about the bible and german
philosophy i remember i remember hanging
out with you one time and i think like
the jordan peterson stuff first started
kind of happening
and i remember you told me you were like
oh i know him you're like he's pretty
good like i remember because you didn't
know like you're like you're like i hear
he's a great professor like you didn't
know any of the [ __ ] before he came
dragged into the
yeah and then of course you see now like
10 years later he's like
you can't fire me i quit basically to
the institutions so but i can see why
like i watched some of his lectures on
uh live that he delivered at ut and like
he was a good lecturer like he was
engaging he kept the material down to
earth he always like talked to the
audience sometimes i would sit there and
be like we were supposed to be talking
about x and now we've moved through to
talking about y z and pretty much every
letter of the alphabet but we haven't
even talked about x but still you know
it was a kind of entertaining spiel and
you're like okay i can see why he'd be
popular with students he knows how to
give a good sermon in the classroom yeah
definitely definitely definitely a
sermon um this is for a lot of people
who feel alienated from religion
and now they're permissed to re-enter it
through
psychology
learn about chaos dragons and all the
good stuff oh yeah
all right so uh what do you say we start
out with the first clip you know what
this clip is
it's from the very beginning
oh it opens with a [ __ ] bang yeah
yeah it's kind of like one of those star
wars movies where everyone begins with
like a giant ship and like a battle or
something like that it's just like man
are we even gonna [ __ ] talk all right
let's check this out
it's requiring a lot of thinking and
then i have to like look at the
criticisms of this guy and criticisms of
the work and you know you know who
believes that in 10 years miami's going
to be underwater who believes that this
is probably hyperbole and that it's a
gross exaggeration and the reality is
you know the world sort of always goes
through these cycles of change but human
beings are definitely having an effect
on it but a small effect compared to
cows and other other things it's like
it's hard to sort out the climate cows
which have nothing to do with people at
all cows have nothing to do with
agriculture they just happen to be here
they just keep farting
and that's what bothers me about the
climate change types it's like the types
this is something that bothers me about
it technically it's like
climate is about everything
it's okay
but your models aren't based on
everything your models are based on
a set number of variables yeah so that
means you've reduced the variables which
are everything
to that set
well how did you decide which set of
variables to include in the equation if
it's about everything
and that's not just a criticism that's
like
if it's about everything your models
aren't right
because your models do not and cannot
model everything what do you mean by
everything when you say it's a good
question
that's what that's what people talk
about the climate apocalypse claim in
some sense we have to change everything
it's like everything eh
okay what and the same with the word
environment
that word doesn't mean
it means so much that it actually
doesn't mean anything like when you say
everything's a lot in a sense that's
meaningless right because
well what are you pointing to well i'm
pointing to everything well what's the
difference between the environment by
the way everything i'd like to interject
and say this is from a man who once said
that
beliefs make the world in a more than
metaphysical sense now hectoring people
about not being analytically precise
enough when it comes to defining things
like environment so climate climate is
everything including like like like
literary enjoyment is part of climate
like i don't know do you need to take
that into account it's just strange it's
really weird what i realize upon
listening to this is that really every
science uh is pseudoscientific because
physics is also about everything
allegedly and who knows what the
physicists are not actually
incorporating who knows what they're
living in so i just think that we have
to abandon isaac newton einstein and all
those others it's kind of it it kind of
leads to like his like on a serious
point like that his
his objection is really
like a really stupid like skepticism
it's just like about it's like the
skeptical retort it's like well you
can't include everything so well what
drives me now
is like
probably 15 minutes after this he says
my colleagues and i at the university of
toronto developed a schematic index to
test individuals creativity
so what did the creativity take into
everything you take into account
everything into account is it everything
is creativity everything no he's just a
climate scientist don't you understand
that's what it is well he's selected for
variables psychology is part of the
climate yeah it gets really uptight
about people who criticize things like
iq and they'll say things like well if
you want to get rid of testing about for
things like iq then you might as well
just get rid of the whole
psychometric tradition because it is the
most accurate gauge we have of how it is
that people actually behave and think
and it's like really so climate is more
complicated than intelligence and we
aren't just abstracting from somebody
yeah
that's a that's a good point he he he
takes a lot of like evolutionary
psychological insights as like gospel as
well
where lobsters
which is very much a dismal science
bonobos
although actually he never talks about
bonobos i noticed that he always looks
sorry always talks about chimpanzees he
doesn't talk about bonobos because
bonobos would be like would lead to
socialist conclusions so like he likes
to talk about aren't they matriarchal
they're matriarchal and they also solve
all their problems by having orgies and
they're adding something they're
dominated by chaos they're a chaos
species a lot of chimps are polyamorous
yeah so chimps
bonobos it's very different no bonobos
or so bonobos and chimps are actually
both i learned this evolutionarily
they're like i don't they're just as
close to us as chimpanzees so like
really they're just as close they're
they're actually pygmy chimpanzees
basically but they're marxists but but
they're marxists they're mature they're
matriarchal they're cooperative and like
they don't have wars whereas like
chimpanzees are brutal and they like
they have wars and they kill each other
and like bonobos don't do that they like
as soon as tensions
arise like the females come in and
basically just offer themselves up and
they they defuse everything with sex
well that's like i always said you know
apparently there was one simian in that
clan who conceived of the simeon version
of like john lennon's imagine started
playing it for them
lay down their arms and decided that
they were just gonna love one another
sometimes well but i think but i think
it is it is but it is interesting to me
and i remember a while ago i read a book
about how like
it they they kind of observed the way
like everybody likes to use chimpanzees
as the example to talk about how brutal
human beings are but then don't talk
about bonobos even though they're just
we're just as related to bonobos and
jordan peterson does the same thing he
just talks about chimpanzees about how
brutal they are and like the k and like
the the kind of war-like aspects of them
and but all but neglects to talk about
bonobos no i i've never found that kind
of argument from evolutionary biography
uh biology particularly i like that
evolutionary biography what would that
be let's make that up oh we should play
that game again what was that
that game where we uh where we make
invent words and decide what they're
called yeah yeah i mean that's the
meaning of that
but no no i've never really found that
argument from evolutionary biology all
that strong since there are plenty of
instances where we've transcended the
limitations of a biology and that's a
morally good thing sure but what also
baffles me about this is how little
understanding he seems to have of the
scientific method as expressed by
somebody like popper because any decent
scientist will point out that absolutely
you have to exclude a huge number of
variables in order to run experimental
tests i mean how else would you actually
produce anything that was of value but
science doesn't operate on a one-to-one
basis where one individual runs a test
and says i've now concluded everything
that there is that's worth knowing about
a given phenomena science is cumulative
because there are many different people
in the scientific community we'll
sometimes run the same test again and
again and complementary tests and
through that we gather a stream of
knowledge about a given phenomena and
we've been doing that about the climate
now for
what is it now pills like 60 years 70
years or something like that so
there's really not much debate any
longer that whatever test you run the
earth is getting warmer and it has some
association with the huge volume of
hydrocarbons and other chemicals that we
release into the air okay
that was heavy do you think i just think
it's hilarious that he gets off to a hot
start like this and right after this i
don't know do you want to continue the
class i was just going to say though
like does joe rogan challenge him let's
see let's see let's see okay let's see
it does kind of throw the gauntlet down
a bit what's the difference between
climate and everything
well there's there's no difference so
this is a crisis of everything it's like
no it's not like the storms of jupiter
it really is then we're done because we
can't fix everything well
what they mean specifically is the human
what what human beings are doing that's
causing the earth to warm right right
joe rogan patiently explaining the
anthropocene to jordan peterson
man i got some respect for joe rogan
actually because i haven't seen him
since here in fact logan is not nearly
as bad as people are making him out to
be yeah he platforms he platforms a lot
of people that are like a bit whatever
cringe but he's a bro but he also and he
also gives them enough space with which
to hang themselves because like three
hour conversations you can kind of suss
out like on what level i don't know how
much of this you guys actually watched
but like i did watch like probably the
first two hours like somewhat carefully
like watching and it did feel to me like
joe rogan was
like
a bit like puzzled by a lot of the stuff
that peterson was saying like i feel
like but when they used to have
conversations in the past
uh joe rogan was relatively impressed by
peterson like he felt like they would go
on rifts but i did feel like this time
joe rogan would be like a little bit
like hmm i don't know he's asking those
hard-hitting questions like what do you
mean by everything
this is what i mean
2016 himself now and i don't want to
enter too much about his biography
because that's neither here nor there
but back in the day if you listen to him
talk around 2016 2018 he'd be relatively
analytically precise he would
acknowledge his limitations and if he
was talking about something that was
outside of his disciplinary expertise
aside from post-modernism uh you would
usually say like this isn't something
that i really know that much about but
and kind of offer an opinion about it
now he's just going off on all these
wacky kind of tangents where he seems to
assume that he knows everything there is
to know about climate modeling the
scientific method why it is that it
doesn't apply in this circumstance and
you're just kind of like dude you're
kind of getting out there now well that
you're you're bordering on being that
dude on the internet who sits there and
it's like
i am like a big fan of scientology
because i'm a psychologist a scientist a
metaphysical philosopher i also stand
against the elites who are trying to
deny knowledge of these alien invasions
to you
but that's the key word too matt elites
right he's just adopted the ultimate
contrarian position like it's not really
even about climate so much it's just
like about saying the craziest thing
right off the bat just to let you know
like he's done with the system man he's
just it's just a really it's a really
stupid way of of of like just casting
doubt that's what i meant earlier when i
said like skepticism it's just like a
really weak like way of getting into
this skeptical argument which is like
the most
like i remember when i was in my
philosophy grad school and my master's
like that that was kind of like the
argumentative moves that people would do
is kind of like the final like the last
ditch like kind of nuclear option
it's just like well skepticism you can't
know anything right it's like it's like
the last ditch nuclear option in a way
he's like pressing that button here when
he's like well it's about everything
can't
can't account for that i don't want to
continue on this because it's kind of
boring but
he does go into all of the benefits of
fracking after this you think he's like
on the the heritage foundation well you
should play that it's kind of funny
because because joe rogan does challenge
him on that it's pretty funny i mean we
don't we don't know anything about this
he obviously doesn't know anything about
it but like the benefits of fracking you
don't kill the oceans no but there's
literally a point when joe rogan's like
but it pollutes the water and stuff he's
like not really
like what
you should i wish you had that queued up
because when the bp oil spill happened
it created all kinds of new species as
they mutated because there are now all
kinds of healthy chemicals in the water
that weren't there before that's
actually so i was gonna i was gonna
share before there's like
uh someone i know like i'm gonna i'm
gonna withhold their their name for this
but like uh it's it's um they send me an
email there's someone academic and uh
they like they sent me this story and
they said you know i was very good a
very good friend of jordan peterson back
in the day i haven't seen him or tammy
since 1998. he used to talk about
academia as a benign social and
political force in mainstream society is
this to you personally yeah oh he's like
he complained then about post-modernism
and political correctness i never
thought that i would look back at our
conversation between friends over dinner
and alcohol
would someday lead to his ideas becoming
so public and him becoming so popular i
remember often telling him he was an
idiot
you know like friends do when they
disagree it's made me rethink how some
some of those ideas can take on a life
of their own so yeah it's just funny
though like all right so i have that
queued up
everything is post-modernists okay good
let's see what he says about that
the story of abraham's very cool story
because abraham's like 80 years old
living in his father's tent oh we have
to do some bible stuff first of course
and god shows up one day and says i love
the bible you have to leave everything
you know and journey out into the
unknown
and you think well what is that
well that's the call to adventure
that's what it is
and so and what happens to abraham is
it's a bloody catastrophe like the first
thing he runs into is a war and then he
goes into a totalitarian state egypt and
they try to steal his wife and it's like
man he's thinking
things are pretty good in that tent
but
well he goes on this tremendous
adventure and then he's the forefather
of of you know
biblically speaking half the people on
the planet he has this tremendous
adventure
think well what do you said against the
suffering of your life
well the adventure of your life
that's what you said against it it's not
safety you forget about that there's no
safety for mortals that's for sure and
besides safety
that's what you want
you don't want that you want adventure
so then the question is where's
adventure to be found in exploitation
i'll try it see hell is to be found in
exploitation
how about true who thinks adventure is
to be found on exploitation well that's
kind of the claim that everything's
about power
everything's motivated by power is that
really what people say though who says
that
i
just all say that that's such a silly
experience yeah but that is what joe
puts his hand up in sunday's school
house
that's right
where are you
the mouthpiece of political ideology
when you're making paintings that's
motivated by power yes because you want
to climb up the socioeconomic status
hierarchy by painting
that's ridiculous you're just not very
good at it okay what about music
same thing motivated by power you bet
everything is motivated by power well
that was at this point you can tell like
jordan knows the hole he's stuck himself
into he's just going to keep digging
accepted
everything's why do you think that the
main culture i do
children finger painting
okay so hold on to be fair
i do think that like there's like so
jordan peterson's not explaining it
properly but like there is a way in
which you could you could talk about
fukodian power
as like actually being but it's a
different kind of power like because
because
jordan peterson's conflating like a kind
of marxist like don't like like like uh
like a press or an oppressed form of
power whereas foucault talks about power
as like actually a creative energy that
like that makes the social like
constitutive impossible but that's weird
and this is something that we pointed
out in our text because
he should know that because he's
somebody who spent a lot of time
claiming that he read a lot of nietzsche
and caring about that and that's more or
less the way that nietzsche understands
power oh yeah yeah yeah you're right
he's this kind of creative force that's
dynamic can be destructive but
condescending can create values also
that's true and yeah vocal means in a
very similar sense a more critical sense
because of course he talks about
structures of domination and discipline
but he also never denies that power can
be creative productive
can allow you to express your identity
or even create your identity in various
iterative ways like
really this shouldn't be all that
mysterious to somebody who apparently
has spent a lot of time reading single
paragraphs of nietzsche and talking
about them at great length in his class
for hours at a time well the best part
of this was joe rogan like if someone
paints they're just trying to get power
absolutely
they're trying to move up the
socioeconomic hierarchy through like
painting yeah
jackson pollock was like desperate for
thirsty for that i mean i don't know i
think that that's the only i mean i
guess power is the only one
is [ __ ] power is the only thing that
can explain why the hell [ __ ] jackson
got popular i mean
says the person who knows nothing about
art but vincent van gogh when he chopped
his ear off was just like man i'm gonna
get so many girls like [ __ ] like
they're gonna dig this more than
anything else in the whole goddamn world
i'm moving up in the world
you guys like jackson pollock paintings
though like honestly like guys you got
to see him live man
live what are you talking about
in the gala really okay
though like that's just more
intellectual art it's like oh yeah let's
see let's let's riff on this but that's
a different kind of art i mean where's
van gogh it's like i get it like i've
never even seen a van gogh live but like
i get it you know honestly i know
actually nothing about visual arts uh i
mean it's interesting and i appreciate
them but to the extent i have any kind
of preference it's usually for abstract
modernism occasionally a little bit of
pulmonary art but i cannot explain to
you why that appeals to me it just kind
of does
maybe if you push me let's see if he
goes a little bit further in this clip
done a lot by people you have not taken
those chances that that diminishing of
effort by calling a painter or a
musician and saying that those people
are motivated by power
these are from career intellectuals who
don't venture outside of the
universities they don't out venture
outside the prisons of their own
imagination or the echo chambers they
exist yeah yeah no i think a tremendous
amount of it i mean this is nietzsche's
observation and oh my god
a lot of that see this is what i'm
talking about like okay yeah you got it
you got it right there he's talking
about
like
these people read nietzsche fanatically
foucault yeah
i mean he wrote a whole book called
nietzsche they mastered they masturbated
to nietzsche and he's like well
nietzsche would call these people
resentful cowards
yeah and it's extremely annoying also
because
again if you i mean nietzsche probably
would call all of those people he would
think that all those people are wrong no
yeah absolutely probably wouldn't
appreciate the question but not in the
way not in the way that peterson thinks
that he i mean nietzsche was one of the
first people to say that
artistic creation is about power but
like victor pointed out not this kind of
power
narrative but in the sense that you want
to affirm your life through creation
and self of yourself and overcome
yourself exactly through these processes
of creating new values artistic projects
or new grand politics right like but
that's pretty one-on-one also it's not
hard to realize that that's what he's
going for if you read any of the books
relatively carefully if we want to go
deep into nietzsche here though
his appeal constantly is back to western
civilization or you know traditional
values which is the thing that was
nietzsche's greatest enemy was
traditional i mean maybe not socialism
he kind of hated too yeah but
traditional values hated a lot he said
this is just something invented whereas
peterson goes no these are natural forms
they exist in lobsters birds
chimpanzees and humans and we're trying
to turn away from this balance between
order and chaos yeah i mean nietzsche
didn't he just hate anything that was
like
stagnant like so anything that wasn't
cultivating like the best humans from
flourishing and like tradition is one of
those strongest forces that that that
prevents human beings from flourishing
so well he has very strong
anti-socialist anti-egalitarian he would
also like it's also just clearly not the
case that he would like like some sort
of fascist alternative because the
problem with all those other
arrangements is they also lead to
stagnation it's all about like this
perpetual state of self-overcoming and
self-creation that like no one could
ever achieve but like that's what
nietzsche top wanted like he would hate
anything else other than that i think
the problem runs a lot deeper than that
though because one of the things where
nietzsche innovates upon conventional
and frankly less intelligent
reactionaries is he points out a number
of his books that the reason
christianity and christian
traditionalism failed wasn't because of
some external force it's because
christianity
self-secularized uh he points out in one
of his books i think it's the genealogy
of morals that the final act of
christianity was to ask its last
question
which was it's so dedicated to truth for
such a long time and then it has to
question the truth of itself right uh
and he points out that this is the kind
of damning moment where you're so
committed to this kind of platonic
project that you ask yourself is the
platonic christian project worth
anything and the second thing that he
points out is that the real inheritors
of the christian tradition aren't the
reactionaries they're the liberals the
democrats the socialists everybody who
kind of
is invested in mass egalitarian society
because they're predicated on the same
resentment that early christianity was
so the weird thing is from a nietzsche
in perspective if you really want to be
consistent the sjws that he hates so
much are the true inheritors of the
christian tradition whereas he's
defending his weird kind of nietzsche
and traditionalist hierarchies which are
ambassadization both the traditionalism
and of christianity and amnesianism
a lot of that's motivated by resentment
tremendous amount of i think that's 100
percent true and i think we should be
very careful
very careful people weren't nice and
people that you mean there's a great job
i think that's a hundred percent
insulting and [ __ ] on people all the
time and there's everything about his
voice though have you ever noticed that
what is the expression of power then yes
yeah yeah i always think you think
everything's about power it's like
that's a confession buddy the problem
with that is it also it attacks
your your own
perceptions of yourself yes because you
know you know who you are you know what
you're doing that sounds familiar if
you're you're just doing it yeah well
what attitude do you have to yourself if
right if you believe the only true
expression of human existence is to be
found in the will to power that's
correct okay you're a psychopath right
even more when you're pretending not to
be a dismal viewpoint what about
friendship like is that power too it's
all manipulation
you know the saddest thing there's
actually like five years between these
guys peterson sounds like a sickly dying
man like
the chad rogan
it's sad also because
my wife marion points out that one of
the most beautiful things that cover
wrote was actually about homosexuality
where he said one of the reasons that it
poses such a threat to the established
order is precisely because it indicates
that there are other kinds of
loving attachments that human beings can
make that might transcend the domains of
domineering power and dominating power
doesn't want that so if anything
foucault was really sensitive to this
right that you should want more
friendships more relations more kinds of
ways of expressing yourself with people
who have recognized that it's kind of
sad i don't know if he's wrong that
that of building your life around and
nietzsche and will to power would mean
that like
he says you'd be like a psychopath i
don't know
was a nietzsche you know i agree with
you but like i mean i don't know if you
would i don't know i don't know if you
would actually be a you'd actually be a
psychopath but like it's not it's not an
absurd statement that like it would be
it would be problematic because i mean
why does nietzsche always talk about he
talks about like the great souls are
those like it's like the eagle or the or
whatever who who eats the lamb they are
isolated it's true they're isolating
like they so like it's not like they're
they're evil in the sense that they want
the lamb to suffer it's that they don't
think about the lamb
they just eat it right and it's like so
that is kind of sociopathic girls can
can you think of a better model for the
niche and will to power in film than
daniel plainview that's the real
question here is there anyone else who
better exemplifies that kind of
isolating that's good
yeah because if that's the poster child
for nietzsche and kind of like ideology
played through to its logical conclusion
i mean in that case
that's a typical interpretation of
nietzsche
identify with some of those like more
nice flowery interpretations but like i
don't think uh papa peterson's totally
wrong here have any of you seen the
anime series berserk cuckolas we did a
really good video of that this no bad i
love it okay but you gotta finish we got
this is sometimes held up as a
nietzschean hero right in there yeah i
don't know i've never watched it
really it's such a good value watch it
ridiculous yeah ridiculous the best part
of
friendships is laughing and joking
around yeah that's for sure that's the
play for sure absolutely it's the best
part yeah well so you know if you're in
a human humorless group yes what's going
on but that's the same thing as killing
the comedians it's the same thing that
isn't are we in a humorless group that
is a problem i'm a post-modern neo-marx
people generating it themselves they
represent it so that's another reason
why i trust you i mean i've watched the
most humorous list person is people yeah
funny he's actually funny he's having
fun here and like seriously funny
because you'd go
very dark places very successfully and
it's very funny to watch it's like is he
really going to do that
your kardashian devil is like that's one
of the best things i've ever feels very
forced you know that's a good an
indication of that investigation of the
shadows right you went way in there what
spirit is all right whatever he's doing
there i mean
this guy is just a really weird dude you
know he's a really weird i don't know
how he fell into this position of like
harvard psychologist u of t psychologist
but whatever whatever is going on here
he's like an eccentric well it's i mean
it's easy like i i don't want to say
it's easy but like
but like doing psychology is like
psychology you have to back away from
where the implications are
pretty fast well i mean it's just like
listening to this our psychologists we
don't mean to condemn who was it i feel
like someone recently said
um and
i forget who it was that said this but
like it was like when you become a
hyper-educated person in like one narrow
field
people
i said that it's called ultra
crepidarianism but that you could that
you can go but one of two ways yeah
where you can either know that you know
nothing about anything else or you think
that you're an expert in everything yeah
you're like i'm really good at this so i
must be good at everything else and i
think that's what peterson papa
peterson's falling into
here which is really dumb and i think
because he chastises other people
like this is this is actually the danger
of that this is why i think psychology
is clearly more vulnerable to this like
i think any sort of social science or
science it's like it's like philosophy
is like one of the places where i think
it's like built in it's kind of part of
the system is like
you you're much more likely to go like
the former root right where you're like
i don't know anything
about anything else i mean i don't know
any philosopher who who who claims to be
like oh well like i'm in psychology like
nobody i mean i do in fact it used to be
a recurring thing at the bar
people had asked me like why are you
doing degree in law you're smart enough
to be a philosopher i'm like oh well
thank you that's so nice of you to
say but peterson definitely is like it's
just really funny that he doesn't
realize
like how he's making a lot of sweeping
statements about stuff he clearly hasn't
read like enough of it's very strange
all right we're gonna get to king arthur
in a second but first he doesn't ruin
that
before we get to king arthur
i just want to i want to go to
jordan peterson and joan and joe rogan
on are we white oh good oh yeah this is
a good one
and the hits keep coming with us eh and
uh really famous like not just famous
but famous as like a a worldwide
you know
depending on who you ask either you're a
voice of reason and rationality and and
uh you know
personal responsibility or
you're a voice of intolerance and
bigotry and anger and hateful
sexual oppression what did michael
prejudice dyson call you and mean
white mean yeah and and a mean angry
white man hilarious yeah yeah you're not
mean at all yeah that's what's dumb
about that statement you're not mean at
all i am white actually that's a lie too
i'm kind of tan and he was actually
doing that
wow
we're actually guys like a white
neither of us are white well i'm italian
oh no he was brown not black well isn't
that weird yeah it's really weird the
black and white thing is so strange
because it says it's like wow
wait two two white guys arrived at the
conclusion on their own that whiteness
and blackness are social constructs is
that what they just realized i know it's
beautiful it's like no one has ever said
that before like wow baffling so it
turns out that a lot of what we
associate with race is just arbitrary
who would have thought that yeah
that's funny i mean i think i saw uh
david
david pakman talking about how uh
how like he was talking about that clip
also and he was kind of saying you know
this he's like this is an insight that i
had when i was like in grade five it's
like my skin's not actually wait
wait it's actually more like beige and
he's like he's like this is literally
inside i had when i was in grade five
and they're talking about he's like i
remember talking to my teacher and being
like i'm not really white
i'm like beige
and it's like i'm like here here we are
with with peterson and and and uh joe
rogan like having that inside 55 year
old men
oh god what would happen if he actually
went to a beach for a little while he
would walk out and he's like i am now a
colored individual i can't believe it i
have completely transformed my identity
i actually haven't heard the rest of
this clip because
it gets a lot worse
there's such a spectrum of shades of
people unless you're talking to someone
who is like 100
african from the darkest place where
they're not wearing any clothes all day
and they've developed oh god and to
protect themselves from the sun
you know it's even the term black is
weird it's
a and when you use it
literally my color
it becomes very strange yeah yeah you
know
oh god
it's slow so you were asking me what it
was like what is it like to be you like
what is it like to
and then i know you know you've gone
through a lot of [ __ ]
oh so let's turn it back to him god that
was hard no but i just want to point out
that when you're trying to get pissed
off at people for calling you an angry
white man and then you go into like in
the darkest parts of africa there are
people no but that was joe rogan to be
fair
but then he gets
but the real insight there was when he
was like you know calling me an angry
white man it's like well i'm not really
white i'm like actually like like
there's you know
it's just it's such a stereotypically
like white i use the photoshop
eyedropper on my and it wasn't actually
white
no you see how how he got there too at
first he's just saying no i'm not
actually angry and by the way i'm not
actually white and by the way
i'm coming out as trans right now like
he just anything the guy labeled him as
he was just like yeah i wish we had more
precision in language you know we should
really be talking about the beige
no we should talk about beijing beijing
beige privilege
what's interesting is in brazil are
countries like that they do actually
kind of differentiate between like
degrees of white they do exactly same
thing it's not quite like the north
american experience is not universal but
the way these guys are like clumsily
stumbling into this is just like it's
the same in mexico they differentiate
between about four different categories
of people same with south africa that's
what uh what's his name that uh the host
of the daily show talks about that
trevor
i mean isn't that that that is the point
is like these are
socially constructed categories four
specific reasons culturally contingent
for reasons like the one drop rule
obama's the first black president
there's a reason
yeah it's plaster
okay
okay
um
that was glorious now we are gonna move
into the literature
section um there's lots of bible stuff
too that we call oh the bible stuff is
oh oh do you want the truth i really
like the truth stuff do you want jordan
peterson cries about music or the king
arthur stuff first i don't know arthur
so
when arthur
first grips the sword
he's blown off it
now he can pull it out of the stone
because he's the guy he's the long-lost
son of the rightful king
long lost
he said well wasn't everybody opposing
the tyranny of the times it's like yeah
welcome to the world man
welcome to the world we're all long-lost
sons of the rightful king and the kings
are now a tyrant and don't we have to
deal with that and the answer is bloody
well right we do so arthur
who's got his eyes open and he's born in
straightened circumstances and has to
grow up street smart and he's and his
friends are all funny and they engage in
witty repartee and like he's a he's he's
he knows the world from the ground up
grabs the sword he pull it out of the
stone but it he's blown right off it he
can't wield it because he has visions of
his evil uncle
who conspired with
feminine forces of chaos and killed his
father
murdered his father and his mother so
his uncle is a murderer
his uncle's a murderer
well so is your uncle
and so is my uncle
that's our historical guilt that the
lefties weaponize all the time it's like
the soil we walk on is soaked with blood
rightfully
so when simba takes the sword from the
stone the important thing remember is
scar's legacy is tainting him but you
see simba is one of the beige lions so
he's not dark like scar so and the evil
leftists always try to weaponize the
lion king against us by pointing out the
tyrannical systems that are taking place
in africa
yeah that's
yeah i mean yeah it's it's funny is
there more i want to hear more
it's like how do you know your masculine
ambition isn't part of the world
destroying force because yes it is
so so then why when i accuse you of
racism and so forth and and your white
privilege and your masculine privilege
like why don't you just wander off in a
corner and feel terrible and apologize
and the answer is you probably will
because most people do you don't but
most people do and i know why partly
because they're reasonable
if 30 people come after you and say
you're a
racist tyrant
and it's there's 30 of them you go home
and you think 30 people think i'm a
racist tyrant and like i got my flaws
man and
i might be a little racist because we
all have in-group preferences and i
shoot my mouth off sometimes and i
haven't always been the way with women
that i should be and maybe i've
mistreated some people and maybe i did
it too much and
sorry
and then you're a shell right another
mob comes for you it doesn't work at all
do you think that this is uh a factor of
this new way of communicating where
everyone's communicating all at once
it's not just these small groups of
people that you're familiar with that
are in your tribe or that you interact
with from other tribes this is the whole
this is like unprecedented volume of
human beings i think all right so i mean
it goes on but
the meaning of the arthurian myth is we
shouldn't feel like settler guilt
and uh i think we should actually
i'll take a moment here to acknowledge
our male privilege
like if anyone wants to go into the
corner we've got a corner there
well of course because because arthur as
we know was the original indigenous
inhabitant of the english isles and he
was fighting off the colonizing saxons
so very aft uh reference jesus yeah it's
yeah you know it's funny his analysis of
like
the whole guilt complex thing like
i guess like what it's sort of like
missing to me is
um
well like
the like
there's also a way in which people enjoy
like their gills too like a
psychoanalytic thing
yeah which i think he's like not which
is like interesting because he's like
technically psychoanalytically
trained
but but like so it's kind of funny that
i don't know i don't know anything about
union psycho like psychoanalysis to be
fair bring this up in maps of meaning
okay he does okay which is because
honestly because there he's just like
talking about like the social force that
makes us feel guilty but i think like
people really lean into that guilt for
like jewish sons reasons right um
but yeah i know that's that's funny it's
funny
no yeah i mean
this is another point where
once upon a time i would have his
analysis was considerably more
sophisticated because he points out how
it is that many people will sublimate
their guilt and this is kind of the
nietzschean theme right uh as various
kinds of value systems right and then
they try to impose upon others it's not
nearly as creative or interesting as
nietzsche and he doesn't draw as many
radical conclusions but he was aware at
least of the dynamic that you're talking
about
now he just seems to be
running from king arthur to talking
about
colonization to talking about male
privilege talking about how men shrink
online to because they're being
confronted with all kinds of other
people who knows right
uh shall we go to the bible
absolutely i'd love to
this is the clip that you
picked
victor all right let's see what he says
here
if categories just just dissolve
especially fundamental ones
the culture is dissolving because the
culture is a structure of category
that's what it is
right so when in fact culture is a strat
culture
structure of category that we all share
so we see things the same way well
that's why we can talk i mean not
exactly the same way because then we'd
have nothing to talk about but
roughly speaking we have a bedrock of
agreement
that's the bible by the way
oh my god so i just walked through the
museum of the bible
is crazy that was very cool it's a very
cool museum so the structure that's what
the best yeah that's what i figured out
i mean i just figured figured it out
figured it out it was a cool
it was a cool thing to walk through
because
it's it's chronological they have one
floor which is the history of the bible
but it's not exactly that it's really
what it is is the history of the book
now in many ways the first book was the
bible i mean literally
because
at one point there was only one book
like as far as our western culture is
concerned there was one book and for a
while literally there was only one book
and that book was the bible and then
before it was the bible it was a you
know scrolls and it was writings on
papyrus and but it was we were starting
to aggregate written texts together and
it went through all sorts of
technological transformations and then
it became
books that everybody could buy the book
everybody could buy and the first one of
those was the bible and then it became
all sorts of books that everybody could
buy
but all those books in some sense
emerged out of that underlying book and
that book itself the bible isn't a book
it's a library
it's a collection of books
and so
it literally means when i figured out
what was partly because i was talking to
my brother-in-law jim keller who's
the world's greatest chip designer and
has now designed a chip
that's as powerful as the human brain
which is optimized for artificial
intelligence learning by the way and so
i talked to him about that he said you
heard of the internet right so we got
hold on we got
is there is it better oh my god okay
okay
the crescendo is is unbelievable okay
we'll wait for the crescendo i just
wanna
i mean let's get some initial reaction
we know what he's saying like the the
bible is the the foremost book in the
western world and
i mean he goes on to say that the hobbit
is like based in the original story
which is the story of the bible yeah but
anyway we got litvik here so any
response well actually the hobbit is
based on the story of beowulf as any
tolkien scholar would know but i will
refer judgment nah it's he's clumsily
stumbling into some pretty obvious
truisms about obviously the bible's
place in the western canon but yeah just
the way that like
he very clumsily kind of grasped for
these things i noticed also like he
makes this these super vague statements
of course and just backs them up with
like this smidgen of cultural authority
well king arthur well you know moses
well so that's how he keeps getting away
with like these really like really
pedestrian kind of basic observations
obvious truisms but yes let's get to the
crescendo out of curiosity though i just
want to ask my understanding is that the
first written mythology uh was the epic
of gilgamesh i'm not sure about that
actually yes the enuma elish
specifically like the babylonian
creation myth which a lot of the bible
was based off of yeah but it's true yes
it all goes back to the ancient near
east and like pretty much every culture
in that region like had their own kind
of like bible as it were and like this
is just the one that we kind of ended up
with because of the roman
thing yeah i know i i understand that
it's just that was my understanding of
what the world's first book was and yeah
obviously it has a lot of descendants
and stuff but anyway neither here
another yeah and you know the great the
great christian beowulf
who is known for his his charity
his effective advice his sacrifice and
quality okay all right we're getting to
the crescendo let's go there's a
crescendo
hope i didn't know
i've heard of the internet he said
this is way more revolutionary than that
so in any case we were talking about
meaning
jim said
the meaning of words is coded in the
relationship of the words to one another
and the post-modernists make that case
that all meaning is derived from the
relationship between words that's
wrong because
well what about rage that's not words
and what about moving your hand that's
not words so it's wrong but but part of
it's right because
the meaning we derive from the verbal
domain is encoded in the relationship
between words
so
so now then you think well let's think
about the relationship between words
well some words are dependent on other
words some ideas are dependent on other
ideas
the more ideas are dependent on a given
idea the more fundamental that idea is
that's a definition of fundamental
so now imagine you have an aggregation
of texts in a civilization you say which
way are the fundamental texts and the
answer is the text upon which most other
texts depend and so you put shakespeare
way in there in english because so many
texts are dependent on shakespeare's
literary revelations and milton would be
in that category and dante would be in
that category at least in translation
fundamentally
part of the western canon not because of
the arbitrary dictates of power
but because those texts influenced more
other texts and then you think about
that as a hierarchy
okay with the bible at its base which is
certainly the case
now imagine that's the entire corpus of
of linguistic production all things
considered now how do you understand
that like literally how do you
understand that
the answer is you sample it by reading
and listening to stories and listening
to people talk you sample that whole
domain you build a low resolution
representation of that in your inside
you
and then you listen and see
through that
and so it isn't that the bible is true
here we go it's that the bible is the
precondition for the manifestation of
truth
which makes it way more true than just
true
it's a whole different kind of true and
i think this is i think this is not only
literally the case
factually i think it can't be any other
way
it's the only way we can solve the
problem of perception
this is going to sound really good
this is a dope syllabus he's describing
that song wait wait he said too many
words too fast i agreed with half of
them and maybe this is his style i
agreed with the word
but i couldn't
follow the line of like the
bible is truer than truth because it's
fundamental because it's like it's like
everything else everything else the
bible status as a divine text doesn't
even matter because of how much it's
influenced in western culture that's
what he's saying but he's also saying
power had nothing to do with this like
the fact that christian nations were the
ones that colonized the rest of the
earth this is what bothers me so and the
fact that christianity didn't just
invent these myths that they stole them
all in the first place or exactly we
so those are more fundamental those are
more true
iraq is the true civilization yeah well
there is no account to be fair this is
the problem with the broken clock right
twice a day he is right you know there
is something distinctive about the way
that message was articulated in arguably
the hebrew bible because it was no
longer based off of just like okay fixed
at a specific temple or whatever it
became more text based and that's how it
could circulate more easily but now
we're getting into actual anthropology
which is not what he wants to talk about
he just wants to talk about you know
disney and king arthur but yeah that's
the problem he grounds half of his rants
in something that's like debatably kind
of obvious and then he just goes off on
his tangents so yeah that's what he
figured out that's what he figured out
he was like i figured it out it's the
fundamentals or the bible figured it out
true
yeah this week i don't think that he
actually figured that out this is what i
was getting at because
to my mind like there's nothing that
he's saying there that somebody like
harold bloom hasn't said before much
more eloquently much more interesting
about bloom is that he actually takes
most modernism seriously as the latest
evolution of the western tradition right
yeah exactly uh and what's also
irritating to me about this aside from
the fact that he seems to conflate
structuralism and post-structuralism uh
is that he doesn't even acknowledge the
fact that a lot of people have come up
with exactly the same things that he
said
what a [ __ ] noob i know right he
doesn't even say structuralism or
post-structuralism though he just says
inflates post-modernism and france in
the 70s yeah but i mean beyond that i
mean just
i don't know what you think about this
vic but i mean to my mind if you read
any volume of like carol bloom he'd be a
lot more knowledgeable and a lot more
complex and making exactly the same kind
of assertions and he would at least
acknowledge the fact that like pills
were saying there's a big counter
argument to this whole geography of the
western tradition which is that there is
an association between the hegemony of
these belief systems and power and
that's something that's continuously
contested in the western condition
itself right should we actually venerate
these texts and give them the kind of
status they do which of course is also
the subject of a huge amount of great
literature including pieces like
shakespeare
yeah then didn't
harold bloom say word shakespeare
invented the individual human
yeah through like hamlet soliloquies and
everything that there was no reflection
before that again it's like overblown
statements but you get what they're
trying to say like artistically
yeah this is what i mean though like if
you look at somebody like
hamlet as bloom and others point out is
the quintessential modern skeptic right
the person who questions the ore text
that he's inherited
one of the interesting things about this
is of course you can situate him as a
kind of counter-hegemonic figure right
somebody who doesn't buy into the idea
that his father is literally there even
though he says you know this is ordained
and there's this divine ordered nature
that's why it is that you can see me and
there's such a
reduction of the western tradition
through this kind of analysis that it
actually seems kind of
impoverished to me rather than
enlightening or in any way shape or form
like inspiring
no absolutely and like even implicit in
the bible itself of course there's a
very revolutionary message in that way
so it's it's it's kind of hard to even
see ultimately what he's arguing for
here but well this is what i mean when i
said it used to be more complex also
because in that meaning he would talk
about criticism of idolatry for example
right and there's a huge amount of that
in the bible which is extremely
important right and the way that people
will turn from dogmas into these kind of
calcified systems that you're just
supposed to venerate as tradition as
given and he points out that idea like
idolatry can become stale you need to
continuously confront that and that also
needs to be gone now he's just going on
his long tangents about arthur and you
know
hyper masculine stuff and how it is that
the bible is true and true god only
knows
it's a shame though yeah because like
there obviously is a hunger and like a
curiosity for these kinds of like more
intellectual conversations about the
status of western texts and the canon
like the herald bloom stuff to your
point and he's really there aren't too
many other people who are kind of like
even remotely addressing this stuff so
he just kind of falls into this gap and
yeah people still take him half
seriously in some cases but yeah because
i mean i agree i mean
if you're going to get a good education
in western philosophy or any subject you
need to have a kind of working knowledge
of the hebrew bible and the christian
bible and i don't think anyone would
deny that what some people would deny is
that we should treat that as gospel
right you know to kind of coin a phrase
uh and what's interesting of course is
that there are some texts within the
religious edition that would also
be critical of the notion that we should
take everything that a religious person
has said to be gospel because
it can be dangerous you know by the way
do you know what what professor bienner
we had him on the podcast early on
he was like talking about basically what
a what a fascist potentially like
nietzsche and heidegger his latest
project you know what it's about no what
it's about moses
oh yeah yeah and about like what what
what an authoritarian fascist he is
basically
it's really yeah i don't know if i hear
that hammurabi was quite a tyrant
it's really like the inconsistencies
he he presented a paper in our
department recently about like how
like the inconsistencies
in the bible and like how like there's a
lot of like absurd stuff about that that
does like lead to a lot of us and
basically questioning people who give
like a really kind of like egalitarian
spin on the bible
absolutely yeah i know i'm like he's
kind of like responding just like on a
much more pedantic point this is what
also [ __ ] irritates me when he's like
oh the university is [ __ ] filled with
these post-modern neo-marxists and
nobody even knows his things anymore i'm
like really have you actually been in
any political science department like
you'll go through this
to the threshold where you want to
[ __ ] slit your throat like there's so
much stuff about the bible the christian
tradition you'll film through like all
of saint augustine it's so funny that
like even in the very university that he
that he used to work at for a long time
and like literally three floors down or
two floors down where where i am the
department of political science it's
like he would have known that actually
that especially that department had like
a reputation for having a lot of like
very traditional conservative thinkers
yeah or victoria college right i mean
it's literally like northrop frye's
college yeah like it's the home of
structuralism i am the only postmodern
neo-marxist that i know of
and i have to be friends with you guys
because that's what i'm that's well
the pickings are saying do you think
eric is a postmodern neo-marxist too
postmodern person maybe no he's like a
pragmatist yeah he's kind of a
pragmatist i think eric is too weird
eric is like the embodiment of like
kierkegaard's thing like if you label me
you negate me like there's no way to
i think i am literally the only
postmodern neo-marxist at this time
somehow you got stuck with these libs
i don't i don't know i don't know oh
easily
yeah
literary historian let's leave it at
that
all right we have automatically we have
two clips left we have
um peterson cries over music is chaos so
let's do that one and then we have trans
people are an exotic species let's save
that one for all right all right
dance over there right the the
totalitarianism
versus innovation versus giving people
the freedom and and also
removing the fact this clip is actually
too long so i'm not gonna play the whole
thing i'll play the end
because the whole beginning of it is
like
well the chinese are over there and
they're an authoritarian but they're
producing so much so many ideas and
they're producing so many engineers blah
blah blah and then joe rogan
answers
but they're authoritarian so they're not
creative and jordan peterson goes of
course well they're not as creative as
americans but they're also creative blah
blah blah and then we get into
music
and they talk about jimi hendrix a bit
respect
yeah respect hendrix
okay okay
this is this is his philosophy of music
which he came up with
a few weeks ago this week yeah
so music is just like the world
because the world is made of patterns
and then music
everything is music has layered patterns
everything is clogged it's like
everything is music when i go home
well then you move your body and you
want to right the music calls to you to
move your body did i ever tell
with you patterned layers of the world
that's mean i can't believe peterson
invented dancing his music is an analog
of the structure of existence itself wow
and it calls you to take part in that so
maybe you dance by yourself or maybe
even better you dance with someone else
and so then you both bring your bodies
into this patterned relationship with
this multi-layer harmony together in a
spontaneous way indicating that you can
both play and are there for potentially
trustworthy future mates that's
unbelievable no
dance is for mates it's not just your
birthday of course it's got evolution oh
god thanks
for your purpose he's got an
evolutionary you on the border between
chaos and order because
a boring song does exactly what you
expect it to do
and and gets dull very quickly and an
unlistenable song is so random you can't
follow it
and so what you want is predictability
with a leave-in of unpredictability and
then that puts you right on the edge
that's the zone of problems i don't
disagree with that
i do not disagree with this but this is
the stupidest
smart person insight that you could
possibly imagine but you know what music
borders structure and creativity at the
same time you know nobody knows latin
music though like reggaeton i think
would blow his mind but you know what
you know but you know what's important
about like noting when he like when we
don't disagree though is because like i
think those moments when we're like oh
yeah like that makes sense
because it like it helps us understand
and explain why like so many people like
like it's like it's the gateway drug to
the rest of his [ __ ] yeah that's
because like so it's worth pointing out
and being like well yeah like that's i
mean he's right i mean it's very true
that's that is what music is
yeah exactly that everybody knows who
knows anything at all knows
i mean everyone at this table we're a
bunch of snobby ass [ __ ] elite phd's
and we're jealous
the appeal of a rave is that it strips
music down to its most primal elements
so when you really get in there and you
take your shirt off you know it's just
like once
he he talks about punk music i remember
are you talking about your are you
talking about yourself right now
i have a i have a distinct memory in my
mind
i mean you say that victor i saw you at
my wedding he goes in here into punk
music and how punk music punks are
nihilists
but they bump into each other and when
they feel each other bumping into each
other then they can forget their own
nihilism for a second and that's why
there's punk music and this grinding
guard it's like the bees you know they
got to attract the man all right we've
got quick wait i just want to as a punk
fan i want to say that irritates me
because i would take the exact opposite
aesthetic approach to punk if anything
punk is the opposite of nihilism punk
sees significance everywhere the problem
is the world is filled with injustice
and yet there are so many good people
within it that the only possible thing
that we can do is get angry and try to
change it if anything punk invest us in
a huge mission for complete social
transformation in the name of some ideal
of justice that's usually signified
through anger and you know in the mosh
pit
if someone falls down you pick them up
that's punk music
it's real also smoke a lot of cigarettes
and drink a lot of beer but i mean you
know we've got two minutes left on this
one and it's gonna end well i promise
you okay let's go [ __ ] him if he dishes
punk
not cool man
behave yourself so much creativity
inside the structure of the song because
these riffs right right right and
everyone loves oh man i went to this bar
in nashville and this band was playing
kelly's heroes a great guitarist best
guitarist i've ever seen great music
okay so then nashville i remember i
didn't know like anything about who he
was seeing but i remember him tweeting
when he was in nashville
because he tweeted like about with he's
been obsessed with the lockdowns that
hasn't come up in any of the things oh i
know what you're doing yeah and he
actually tweeted like a photo of
nashville like when we were at the
beginning of omicron like when it was
crazy and he said something like he was
like no lockdown's here and he literally
said
god bless the rednecks oh and it was
like in nashville tennessee i'd also
like to point out that at that point
tennessee had the fourth highest rates
of covid infection in the entire u there
were more cases of covet in tennessee
than there were in the whole of canada
yeah i have to say god bless the
rednecks also because i agree they
prevent government overreach i will say
dialectically they prevent it because
you know if a vaccine causes this much
problems then
they're not going to do anything worse
to us yeah that's true
all right we got to get to
uh one minute 39 seconds
i want to listen to it i want to hear it
i want to hear it i'm not bored he gets
he starts feeling himself long and this
brilliant guitarist just goes way out of
limb and
everybody in the crowd it's so it was so
fun to be there they're just thrilled to
death because they're watching this man
doing the same thing that surfers do
he's like dancing on the edge of chaos
and order in this virtuosic manner and
everyone is so
taken by that that it just lifts them
out of the normality of their existence
you know they see this joy just
transfuse them and that's because they
got an intimation of genuine meaning
it's not amenable to rational criticism
which is the thing that i thought that
struck me is so miraculous about music
and why it has this element of salvation
it's like it puts you directly in touch
with the meaning that sustains you in
life directly and it shows you what that
would be which is something like to
observe the harmonious interplay of the
patterns of being stacked on top of one
another and then to bring yourself into
alignment with that which is what yogis
strive to do and what discipline to be
fair i do like music and after two years
ago
we all miss live music we're not going
to laugh again yeah he's not like wrong
no it's just it's just it's just yeah
i'd be like
the significance of music is being on
the boundary of chaos and order which is
where he's trying to like shoehorn his
therian
and also i don't even care the fact that
he's just like
crying about this i care about
his crying about this given the whole
frame of context that this conversation
is in
i think we're [ __ ] for laughing at
him crying but i think there's a few
things i won't laugh at him for getting
addicted to drugs his wife getting
cancer i accept those as as reasons to
real tragedies but then
his realization about music at the age
of 56 is that there's both innovation
and structure in music and that's going
to make it he's just regretting that he
didn't go to more tragically hip
concerts that's the real revelation well
you know i think but but it's it speaks
to something that i've talked about
several times on this podcast which is
just the way that
peterson just
is just sees the world in such a in such
a solemn way in such a deadly serious
way he just like sees the world
with this level of profundity
that there's just like no room
for
like
humor and absurdity like it's like
everything is like because he's on the
edge of tears all the time and i feel
like the problem with him is like
we actually matt and i we were talking
to our buddy isocratic small youtuber
and like we were talking about zizek and
like kind of comparing
to peterson and like i think
it's interesting because they're both
informed by psychoanalysis just in very
different ways and i think what's
interesting about it is that like
you see the way that like for peterson
the profundity of the world is like
overwhelming with like tears or are
ready to overflow at like any second
and it's like jijak is just like he
responds to like the the overflowing
meaning of the world and with just like
the absurdity it's like we're all irony
irony jokes it's like look at us we're
like we're these like creatures that are
like
stuck in this crazy dialectic of desire
and it's like hilarious and it's like
he's laughing at it but like peterson
doesn't know how to laugh on anything
and i think like the problem with
peterson ultimately is he he he
he like doesn't have enough
introspection to realize that like a lot
of the profundity he's experiencing
might be particularly like him like [ __ ]
that happened to him when he was young
like i don't know what his background is
he has like no self-reflectivity and
he's projecting like profundity of the
world onto everybody else and like sees
it as an objective truth but his
profundity is this like if he does not
say this
to these people at this time the world
is about to slide off into chaos so the
stakes for him are very high that's true
honestly like there's no there's no
point in making fun of him for crying
but it's just so funny that this is the
thing
that he's a jazz or a country bar in
nashville is the thing that is going to
bring him to tears
despite like you you'd think that
there'd be certain levels of empathy
that are involved with that that he just
doesn't demonstrate at all because he
talks about
me
the postmodern neo-marxist as this
person who has no friends who hates
everybody you are a pretty humorous
person we all know that right you just
sit down
i was [ __ ] being sarcastic that's a
great contrast
there's things i mean there's plenty of
things to condemn pills for like we
could we could find but like i didn't
know about that i mean
i want one of those hats so i'm
sometimes envious and resentful of the
fact that he has one and i don't but i
can i think you can explain that further
by the way though zuzia peter something
by the fact that look at the societies
in which they grew up right like g-jack
actually struggled with real adversity
and stuff he actually was canceled or
whatever like he had to actually fight
against the real totalitarian he never
thought about that he knows how to laugh
about the world whereas peterson has had
it too good he's had like this cushy
tenure track job and like he sees these
imagined villains grew up in like
this is what happens when you actually
grow up in a pretty like legit country
which is now coming to terms with more
forms of equality and everything and
it's like oh it's you're right you're
actually right there a lot of jack's
humor is
about is humor he talks about from like
the like soviet era and like the
socialist exactly yeah and he's actually
he's much more acclimated to crisis and
everything like that i've never thought
of whereas like and that's the
difference he has a much healthier
approach to like the ambiguities of life
and everything
i do think that i can understand his
appeal in part because of these
reactions and i think one of the reasons
is and you know jesus points this out
inhabiting a postmodern environment the
primary form of cultural expression is
almost always irony and dissociation
from one's feelings uh or meta-level
commentary on how it is that you're
feeling things i think that i can
understand the appeal of somebody who
has a kind of immediacy about them and
seems willing to embrace and even
project his kinds of feelings about any
given situation what i think is really
problematic is exactly what victor was
talking about the fact that he invests
his feelings with such overwhelming
significance always uh and an objective
he's always like a dostoevsky character
on the edge of an epiphany it's just
like it's all motion and yeah the thing
is it works he's talking to the same
people that grew up probably in the same
suburbs of [ __ ] edmonton that he grew
up i can vaguely see the kind of appeal
right because
growing up in a seinfeld or simpsons era
but actually i shouldn't say something's
consistent had some nice cathartic
moments but say is seinfeld error right
there is something that's appealing
about somebody who just acknowledges how
they feel and expresses it right uh
think about david foster wallace in the
1990s a similar kind of figure from when
peterson's growing up
but like somebody who will open their
book maps of meaning with a song with a
quote from the psalm saying i will utter
truth that the world has never yet known
you just have to sit there and think
like this isn't even sincerity or
authenticity anymore this is grandiosity
arrogance and not a little bit of like
hamminess like it's really kind of hammy
at this point where you just think like
[ __ ] chill out dude take it down like
four or five levels i understand that
listening to free bird is a wonderful
experience i like skinner like anybody
else but like
it's not
and that's the level of significance but
to that point as well like it's
perfectly valid to be like that sincere
about the world and everything like that
okay like look at terence malek's films
for example but you don't have to be
such a smart nakey curmudgeon about it
like our friend
yeah but i also think like
again
we have to like acknowledge
the conditions of why he's so popular
right and like and like like so
i think like it means he's right about
something well it's not but it's not
just that it's it's it also tells us
something about like an appetite
yeah totally for sure right like so like
that's important i think to acknowledge
that like
something is not being satiated
by like like the fact that he found this
giant gap
that that it's like the intelligence he
had like that like us like that we just
have been doing a [ __ ] job
of like providing right it's like he's
exposed that in a way because because
it's like there is an appetite for like
intellectualized thinking i mean we can
we can make fun of and poke holes and
like it's worth making fun of but it's
like but the truth is like he is he is
exposing
like something that there is a public
that wants something that's hungry for
like some account of what meaning is i
think that's true we're not we're not
doing a good job of providing it right
so like which is like if we were
he wouldn't be filling that gap and also
this is the reason that we're doing a
podcast on this it's partially our own
jewish science we're jealous of the guy
we're jealous that he has his success we
we're jealous that he has the audience
because we feel like not me i don't need
that you know [ __ ] [ __ ] followers
we put the work in and he's just saying
whatever the [ __ ]
like he farts out of his ass and
i mean that's part of it that's part of
why
intellectuals hate him it's also why
intellectuals hate g-jek because it
feels like oh they're getting they're
getting it too easy so yeah yeah i mean
we should we should just straight up
admit that yeah
we'll admit that we're jealous
that he's that successful
but we're also saying that he's wrong
he was also the perfect storm of course
because he threw himself against like
the ontario human rights court or
whatever like back that's why he caught
on fire people were interested in
because of that he was like the original
political bad boy contrarian yeah and
then they started listening to like
stuff about the bible or whatever but he
kind of stumbled into it you're right he
said you're right he what he did was he
caught on
to like a like a phenomenon like some
woke thing or like something that like
culture he establishes anti-world
credentials
stuff that like most academics are like
you know either just like aren't
interested or well you know to be less
generous just cowards to talk about so
like and he just like leaned right into
it and there's a lot of like
non-academic people regular people who
are like oh wow like yeah that thing
that i heard on the news about like
whatever it's like it never made sense
to me and now like there's someone with
authority saying like it's [ __ ]
and it's like and he's just like riding
that wave right why don't we use this to
transition
transition very i see i just want to say
one last thing which is that i
completely agree with everything that
persona is saying and i think it is
something that we could do a better job
on uh when it comes to the left because
i think one of the things that really
speaks to his appeal is the fact that a
he is sincere and b he does seem to have
a real concrete political project that
he invests with extraordinary
significance it's not concrete though is
it well it's concrete in the sense that
people invest it with a certain level
yeah
it's like restore western civilization
and i can understand the yearning for a
project of that sort i just think this
is entirely the wrong project and in
fact the fact that he transforms these
extremely petty struggles into something
of existential significance is again
really quite funny and he's not the
first conservative to do that by the way
but you know we could on the left try to
do a little bit more to actually say
that look there are reasons to
not be cynical and dissociative and meta
about things maybe we can actually just
say that this is what we really want and
this is what we care about which is also
something zuzia points out a lot right
where he says if you want to be a good
left-wing movement maybe stop trying to
be so clever about things and just say
this is what we want right this is what
we demand you know what's what's
interesting to you about peterson when
in contrast to jesus because i think
peterson what he also offers you know
this is like maybe the more
philosopher king take like or the the
kind of like superiority intellectual
take well he's offering like come like
comforting truths yeah definitely the
public and i think zizek doesn't really
offer the same kind of comforting shrews
if anything he is like dee like kind of
delegitimizing and kind of like
uh you know like kind of being
like
pissing on sacred cows you got to chop
the balls of people in power and
ultimately i think what peterson's
project is which is like what gives a
lot of people some comfort is he's
trying to re-sanctify things and and
make things uh sacred again in a way
all right well
we've transitioned we've given his due
to his due now we're gonna transition to
the greatest hits
that made jordan peterson famous so
trigger warning
um he's walking back
his hate speech i guess
and decided that trans people are just
an entirely different species from the
rest of us
so here we go
you can't joke sacred things yeah
there's there's protected classes now we
all know what they are we don't have to
bring them up you know whether it's
trans people gay people
people of color asian people whatever
those things are
um one thing you can mock relentlessly
is white people
specifically white males it's one of
those they are pretty funny you know oh
sure we're ridiculous but there's a
funny pejorative that people will say
about
like a group of folks they're primarily
white males like that is that's a
pejorative like that's like it's my
audience that's what everyone says yeah
oh you're talking to those those young
angry young white males but isn't that
funny that that is hilarious that means
something negative
does that mean women are more interested
in fiction than non-fiction
and and men are opposite to that so if
you look at book buying preferences for
example women tilt towards fiction and
then tilt towards one fiction and if you
want to know why that is it's because
the most reliable difference that
psychologists have ever found between
men and women the biggest difference is
interest
so women are reliably more interested in
people and men are reliably more
interested in things now there's still
overlap it's one standard deviation
which is a big difference but
that that isn't to say no women are
interested in things because some are
and no inter no men are interested in
people because some are like i'm a man
who's more interested in people than
things that's why i'm a psychologist
you know i actually have a relatively
feminine personality structure because
i'm pretty high in negative emotion and
i'm pretty high in agreeableness and
that's the typical feminine structure
and that that's an interesting
discussion to have too because you know
we have this idea in our culture that
you can be a woman born in a man's body
and that's not true but you can
definitely be a man with a feminine
personality structure like 10 of men are
as feminine in their personality as the
average woman is
and vice versa 10 of women are as
masculine in their personality as the
average man is
now you can move those boundaries around
and say well it's five percent
and forty or something it doesn't matter
but the point is there's plenty of men
who are as feminine in their personality
as the average woman
that doesn't mean they're in the wrong
body it just means that men and women
are more alike than different even
though they are different and that
there's huge range within both genders
and we need to know this so what do you
think is happening with trans people
then
what a question rogan knows
the money shot what do you think is
happening with trans people okay
let's paint them all with a brush at the
same time jordan peterson
go trigger warning a lot of different
kinds of trans people first trans men or
excuse me trans women men to female
well then i would say it depends on
what period of time
you're asking that question about
right now if you look at teenagers for
example who want to switch genders
95 of them are unbearably confused
that's what's causing that and i think
there's other reasons too i think this
is a conjecture
when the when the trans
teenagers came after me when i opposed
bill c-16 in canada on compelled speech
grounds i i spent quite a bit of time
watching them i already kind of knew
about that
fluid identity crowd
and tattooing started to become a
cultural rage and i was interested in
well who's doing this because i knew it
was
it was a practice that was limited to
criminal subtypes
but then all of a sudden it started to
make its inroads into the popular
culture so what an art
a group of early adopters of tattooing
and piercing
from the perspective of personality like
who are these people and they were all
highly creative people
well what it and creativity is a trait
and all people who aren't creative
that's wrong in fact most people aren't
creative at all and i can explain that
later but they're not
we get we developed a scale called the
creative achievement questionnaire which
assesses lifetime contribution to 13
different creativity take a new account
everything that your scores would range
from this is where everything comes from
i think it was eight
no
70 of people
if you sum their scores across all 13
domains scored
zero
and i ask audiences like
how many portraits have you painted
zero how many songs have you composed
zero how many plays have you written
zero
how many recipes have you stopped let me
stop you
the tattooed types are high they were
high in creativity okay and a lot of
these people who are fluid in their
identity
are actually high in trade openness and
they do have fluid identities and some
of them are feminine men and masculine
women
so yeah
but that doesn't mean that surgery is
the cure for that that it does not mean
that
it does not mean
this is such a gross over generalization
as well as if all trans women get
surgery but anyway yeah so it's it's
disgusting all the way down but it's
like
i'm this is a
specialized group of people
if we evaluate the group
then we can understand so it almost
sounds like he's trying to walk back
other stuff that he said and he's trying
to say something like
well trans people aren't all bad because
they're the creative types
yeah it's uh yeah i mean
it's definitely a bizarre take it's a i
mean it's a strange i mean he knows this
is his brand too so he has to kind of
like say something about it but he can
yeah it's
yeah it's interesting i was think like
there's this random youtuber i was
watching recently and he has this like
really weird take on
like trans issues that is reminding me
of what peterson is saying which is just
like that he just thinks it's on the
spectrum of like
any sort of body modification so he was
talking about like tattoos and stuff
like that yeah that's on you're on the
that's the gateway drug exactly it's
just like any sort of like modification
where you're trying to like escape from
yourself is kind of like this theory i
don't agree with it but i'm just saying
like so it's like so when you cut your
hair so it's like when you do so yeah
exactly so but it's all so for him it's
like all on the spectrum so it's like
that's a smaller one right like and his
thesis is like none of us really want to
be who we are
we're all like trying to escape to some
extent it's just some of us want to
escape more so first you dye your hair
exactly and you get piercings and then
you become transgender even thinks he
even thinks makeup is on that spectrum
but it's just like and then it's just
like that's well i mean i'm not saying i
agree but i'm just saying it reminds me
of what peterson marshall mcluhan had a
really good quote about this where he
said look
to imagine a naked human being is the
same as imagining a beetle without its
shell right
we are people who fundamentally
transform ourselves that's intrinsic to
who it is that we are and so to imagine
that these kinds of transformations are
artificial or strange is really just not
to understand what it means to be human
now that doesn't mean you have to agree
with every kind of weird thing that
people do
but it does mean that you should at
least appreciate that this kind of
variety is going to be intrinsic
to any kind of human society that you
encounter well do you see the way that
he's doing this because he's saying
in the same way that you'd say
or i don't know like a
a crystal gripping person would be like
well the indigenous had such a pure
understanding of nature
and they until we came and ruined it
so like this the self-affected person
he's giving
trans people like oh you have this
domain you're not really people you're
just like overly creative so you extend
your creativity to your gender because
you really seem that you're not really
people either no by saying this by
saying you are a class like this oh
right okay they're the half elves in the
dnd pearson cosmology is every
transgender person you know creative or
are like
a few of them just math nerds that are
just nerds in every other category and
not creative yeah i mean i mean i think
that's true this is this this is
[ __ ] because he's exoticizing trans
people like he i think he thinks in his
head he's giving them a compliment
coming back from the old [ __ ] that he
said about them
that is like i'm not going to use your
preferred pronouns because that's uh
discriminating my use of language so i
will say that i have anecdotally noticed
an over representation of like
queer in the broad category in like
philosophy and like creative endeavors
and i i've always thought of this like i
was kind of just like
in my own sort of like folk
psychological intuitions i was like well
it makes sense to me because like when
you feel like you don't fit in to this
world you just have to think about the
world more that because you're like
because you're like well i like what is
this world that i don't fit into
so therefore you are just like gonna be
like thinking and so it just seems
intuitive to me that you would be more
likely to be in philosophical or
artistic fields because you're always
you're noticing things when you fit in
the world and when you fit in with the
world there's a lot of things you don't
notice right like but when you don't fit
into the world and you're trying to like
let's say become like trans and like i
remember my my girlfriend she used to
have a roommate who who was a trans
woman and i remember hearing her kind of
talk about like make comments that like
kind of spoke to the way she's like
paying meticulous attention
to like you started
like in what way so it's like you were
just forced to pay attention in a way
that like so he's saying something
opposite he's saying you're creative
and then
that creativity extends into your gender
and you're saying no you start
with like not fitting in which is the
thing that makes you create it exactly
right yeah and that's it i think that's
a good
amenable to the second explanation than
the first yeah especially because i
would actually say that's more consonant
with the general outlook oddly enough of
western civilization as a whole right i
mean you go back to something like plato
and socrates one of the catalysts for
the philosophical enterprise is the fact
that the philosopher doesn't feel like
he or she belongs
in the human community which is one of
the things that stimulates them to start
to think this way right like why do i
not belong why do people have these kind
of projects why is that people believe
what they believe so i actually think
that if anything you're affirming a more
ancient kind of wisdom than he is right
anyway so well done i just want to say
in some i'm a student of brazonism on
this point i think that the zoniest
approach to understanding these issues
is better than okay well i mean this is
this is feeling kind of dark to me so
i'll give him another maybe minute and
uh then we'll wrap it up after that all
right all right
well what do you think it means when
someone is so
attracted to the idea that they
were born in the wrong body they're it
means so much they're so compelled that
they're willing to go through surgery to
change
got it changed all sorts of things i
knew a kid in toronto who was on the
autistic spectrum and a lot of the
people who were manifesting serious
issues with gender identity or on the
autistic spirit okay no i can't do this
anymore
so
first of all amongst women trans people
are overly creative but now they're also
autistic so i think i'm i'm i'm done
with this [ __ ] i mean that's that's
strange i mean i i wonder if there's
actually stats to back that up i mean
i'm trying to be charitable here no he
says he had a a student in toronto i
don't know anyway
[Laughter]
he's returning to the hits now he's like
uh trying to extend
i mean maybe put his best foot forward
and saying trans people are creative but
they're still
an exotic
species if you let me next yeah guys
mark my words in like five years he's
gonna be the next caitlyn jenner like
he's gonna come out as trans he's just
gonna be when he sees his popularity
he's just like
he'll be jordan but with a y and jordana
same debates were happening about gay
people like gay people are just
confused now that just
suddenly slips under the rug for these
conservative no but that that does point
to something though which is the speed
with which these changes have happened
like gay marriage was being debated just
like 10 years ago and now that's like on
a accompli now it's like okay trans
rights and everything and there is
something to be said about how quickly
this has happened especially in certain
parts of north america that people are
like not necessarily uncomfortable with
it but they just don't have the
vocabulary for it yet and that's why he
can kind of speak to that more confused
crowd yeah yeah to be fair like a lot of
my more conservative friends and
associates that's exactly what they say
i mean
one of my intelligent conservative
friends i won't name them basically said
like
10 years ago i was asked to accept gay
marriage and i did and now i'm being
asked to accept this and i'm just not
sure what the next thing i'm going to be
asked to accept is it's all happening
too fast now i don't necessarily
sympathize with that view in the sense
of thinking it's intellectually cogent
but i do empathize it with this you
understand why there's a space for
somebody like him then to then kind of
like complain about it and understand
why people might come in and question it
we gotta go one at a time but this is
like victor just said this is why
he this guy has the the wave behind him
that he does it's because like people go
trans people
[Music]
like as if it's up to you to just make a
decision a medical decision in many
cases about someone else's life but can
i just this guy voices those concerns
yeah true true i mean i just want to add
like a kind of like to add on to matt's
point sort of like about having empathy
for like people i think that like
there is
you know a bit of a conservative
reactionary potential in all of us and i
think like and it's interesting that
when i was studying urban planning i did
my masters in urban planning as like
also and i remember
like one of the things that like you
know whether you're on the left or the
right we see this all the time is like
people
complain when things change yeah so like
when you're gonna build a new building
or something somewhere it's like or
tearing something down it's like it
doesn't matter if you're like lefty or
like a right winger like you're gonna
find people who are gonna be like i
don't want that to change i mean i mean
i'm just saying like that is a human
that is like a part of human nature look
at this because it's gone through so
many generations and every single time
again iteration i get bombarded with
people being like it was so good the way
it was before man why the [ __ ]
when they put [ __ ] news feed on
facebook
that's when i canceled it my only point
is just like it's just that like it's
not that weird
like to to for a conservative to be like
you know i accepted this thing like i
think it's it's in in a way that
potential is in all of us yeah and i'd
like to point out like conservatives are
sometimes the more reflective and more
intelligent conservatives usually
acknowledge that there's a high degree
of irrationalism in their position uh
you know i mean russell kirk author of
conservative mind which is you know a
positive book he's an idiot though yeah
i mean he's a weird guy but one of the
things that he says that i think is
right is that conservatism is first and
foremost a disposition uh rather than a
philosophy wasn't that wasn't that
didn't he just steal that from uh what's
his name the uh evan burke uh no no not
well edmund burke i guess but like i was
thinking of the other guy the 20th
century conservative person
yeah i mean these guys are away at the
end of the cast it's not the time to
start name dropping the point is that
like
there is this kind of conservative
reaction that people do have like i
don't like when facebook changes either
i sit there and i'm like what the [ __ ]
and when changes happen too rapidly
there's a part of me that thinks like no
i like things the way they were before
or even if i didn't like them at least i
had a set of expectations about how my
life was going to go and all of a sudden
that's been upturned so definitely i can
empathize i just don't sympathize
because sometimes i think well there's
no real reason for me to adopt this kind
of attitude so on second tier reflection
maybe it's better that things change
maybe that means that it'll improve
maybe it means that things will be
better or actually upon
looking at the evidence that seems like
this will be better and i don't think a
lot of conservatives
typically do that or many of them don't
that's true that's true they kind of
settle into the reaction and that's
where they stay
yeah i was just gonna say yeah and this
is sadly why like
a culture war profiteer if you will like
peterson can kind of like get away with
his [ __ ] for so long it's because
especially in a country like the us
where like you know you have to have
sort of like you universalize things
quite quickly where if something is
happening in san francisco or new york
it does kind of spread to the rest of
the states pretty quickly even if
culturally maybe they're not really at
the same you know they're not ready to
accept the same kind of things it's
because it's all like it's this loose
coalition or federation of states
ultimately that you know
the same things kind of all happen in
the same way but yeah
it's it's the problems with the
political system as much as anything
else
is academics oddly enough despite being
broadly speaking culturally left are
some of the most personally conservative
people i know like most academics are
like i like my coffee like this i like
my books laid out like this i like my
computer like this creatures of habit
yeah creatures that i actually my
girlfriend's like she has these like i
always kind of make fun of her because
she likes like traditions and yeah i
always just tell her i'm like when she's
like something comes up she's like we
did it before and i'm like i'm like
that's how that's how we always done it
that's how we're always gonna do it and
it's like that's just this is like this
this thing that i think exists in people
that it's just like they just want to
keep doing things the way that they are
yeah that's not because it's the best
way it's just because it's like is what
i've done not a great way to wrap this
up because we were having so much fun
and now i'm just feeling like
real oh well i mean i don't know i think
it's i mean it's it's just a point about
human nature the fact that like we all
have some conservatives there's no such
thing as human nature victor i mean i
don't know that's the post-modern
neo-marxism and i'm seeking
i mean there is such thing as there is
such thing as human tendencies we can
all agree we enjoy nachos there's such
thing as habit i think part of the
problem also is victor is speaking in
his really solemn voice like well but
you know there is this kind of thing i
feel like my girlfriend said it
remember he speaks in a solemn voice i'm
like when his girlfriend said it you
know it has to be no but i mean i don't
even think i don't even agree i don't
have the same tendency that she's why i
converted
him can we just quickly end on jordan
peterson crying about a song that he
heard in nashville normality of their
existence you know you see this joy just
transfuse them and that's because they
got an intimation of genuine meaning
and it's uh and it's it's it's not
amenable to rational criticism which is
the thing that i thought that struck me
is so miraculous about music and wise
has this element of salvation it's like
element of salvation
all right
to all of our listeners to everyone who
is
watching this cast
of jesus please listen to whatever song
brings you to tears in the same way that
jordan peters praise and
i mean at least for my part i'm going to
attempt to no longer bring him up
because i think it's been brought up i
think western civilization has been
defended
as much as it will be defensive yeah
yeah yeah and then they're never gonna
make another friday the 13th movie
jason's dead forever come on i mean i
don't think we can get away from him
forever but thanks for hanging out with
us um it's the first time i've ever
really been drunk on the podcast yeah
the booze are flowing so thank you to
litvik
politics vic
matt
matt's keeping his uh dead soldiers next
to you
and shout out to nashville which is a
great music city guys it's called
nashville we never look at this idea
yeah also i want to point out jimi
hendrix and skinner big fan kind of
[ __ ] this guy but you know what he's
like not he's not the devil by any means
and he's not and he's not like he's
just stupid
he's just i mean he's he thinks he's a
lot smarter than he is because he has
like a we talked about it can i just say
so we will
wait do you have something before we
sign off
oh yeah
just
having read a lot of conservative people
that's 99 percent okay we have nothing
to do i want to know if you're saying
i'm sorry i'm sorry you're [ __ ] pills
is such an [ __ ] no it's just no i i
heard the speech coming up because he
inhaled
having read a lot of these people a lot
of them are like that where there's
colonels of insight usually kernels of
literary insight that's one of the
interesting things what about the guy
who wrote american marxism no i mean
that's just a piece of [ __ ] that
deserves to be burned irradiated and
then sent to the moon and then the moon
should be blown up afterwards okay so
and then we should ban it so i didn't
mean to i didn't mean to i didn't mean
to put you on right now but i mean like
every now and then there's a couple of
insights that they have in there but
like what you need to do and you should
be is be better than most conservative
intellectuals are because they rest with
their inclinations and associate so much
more fun to do with them and they never
bother to move on to the second stage
which is asking whether these
inclinations are actually rational or
defensible and
everyone who listens to our podcast
should be better than that well why
don't we finish on a toast a cheers to
thank you to like dumb conservatives
or like at least questionable marginal
conservatives
for existing because they give us
something to laugh and talk about so
i'll drink to that salad yeah
but we can't laugh also because we're
post-modern neo-marxists well i mean i'm
not a [ __ ] post-modernist you had to
go to the american marxism point you
just know how that book's triggered all
right
everybody this has been the
pillpod69 a number which has
no significance whatsoever
goodbye and good night peace peace
[Music]
[Music]